With age comes wisdom… and Ugg boots.
For "The Big Bang Theory's" Kaley Cuoco,
Penny’s cleavage-baring tank tops and
Juicy Couture zip-ups didn’t always fit.
"The Big Bang Theory" was on the air for
a total of 12 seasons and 279 episodes,
so it makes sense that the sitcom ended up
changing over so many years. According to
Cinema Blend, the pilot featured completely
different characters, like the much darker,
tough-as-nails character Katie,
instead of the gentler Penny.
Early episodes of the show also emphasized
the massive gap between the nerdy scientists,
like Leonard and Sheldon, and their hot neighbor,
Penny. This slowly changed throughout the show
as the writers took more time to develop the
ensemble cast and flesh out the relationships.
Co-creator Chuck Lorre noted in USA Today,
"The characters grew. It
expanded the relationships
and what the characters were capable of doing."
One thing that especially
changed was how Penny was
treated in the series — and even how she dressed.
In earlier seasons of the show, Penny dressed
sexy, wearing revealing outfits that flashed
cleavage and almost always featured a tank
top. As the seasons ticked by, though,
the waitress began dressing more formally and
was covered up much more than she used to be.
Penny actor Kaley Cuoco has thoughts
on her character's wardrobe evolution,
and her feelings on the shift
are what you might expect.
In an interview with W Magazine,
Cuoco said that at first she didn't
mind wearing Penny's revealing clothing
during the early seasons of the show.
"I started Big Bang at 21 years old.
I was the cute girl next door to the
nerds [who] was all about booty
shorts and Juicy Couture zip-ups."
But as Cuoco and Penny got older, the style
didn't feel right for the character anymore.
"All of a sudden, it's like,
'Can I have a long-sleeve shirt? How
about a slack? How about a loafer?'"
The Emmy-nominated actor joked about wearing
Uggs with shorts all the time and said she
was sick of wearing high heels. However,
Cuoco doesn't feel like the sexy
clothes took away from her performance.
"I don't think it was hard to
wear that stuff and be funny.
I think I love being funny no matter what."
To her, a lot of Penny's comedy
was self-deprecating, which worked
perfectly. Clearly, she can knock out
a comedic performance no matter what,
as we saw in "The Flight Attendant"
and the "Harley Quinn" animated series.
While Kaley Cuoco eventually became sick of
wearing heels and miniskirts, co-star Kunal
Nayyar hated Raj's unflattering clothes. Raj
often dresses in a combination of sweater vests,
windbreakers, and cargo pants that make sense
for a young male geek. Nayyar told Page Six,
"I think the discussion that happened with the
costume designer is that because he's in a new
country and because he's a genius at such
a young age, the layers act as protection."
However, if Nayyar's Instagram page is
anything to go by, he tends to dress in
elegant and stylish fashion. It's why he told
Deadline in 2019 that he would be burning his
character's cargo pants once the show ended. He
also took on some new television roles where he
couldn't be typecast as Raj, including the
Netflix series "Criminal" and the Apple TV+
series "Suspicion." Ultimately, both Cuoco
and Nayyar seem to have transcended their
former sitcom characters' style, whether that
involves Juicy Couture zip-ups or windbreakers.